we'll get better game after game after
game we'll get smarter
we'll play better we'll play everything
all right keep your heads up
well that was shortened to the point uh
so what do they have to do better
uh first of all ernie me and kenneth we
talked about it before the game
we talked about at halftime and we're
going to talk about it now
every time they run a pick and roll the
center is below the free-throw line do
we have that play
you can show any play right now if you
you ain't got to show a particular play
show the show penny those were because
all right wait freeze it up go back go
back get started back start it over and
if you freeze it here
well we don't have to we can't see where
bobby is but right now bobby port is
freezing here
is is actually in the paint so freeze it
there
if freezing there that's not a pig
if he gets lost or picked
trae young is wide open and if i'm the
point guard and i'm drew holiday
there's no way i'm going to be able to
guide god of god dancing so now
as the play develops you'll see where
bobby portis is coming from
freeze it right look where he is freeze
it there there is no way
john collins that he could be in the
paint there
and guard the most prolific scorer
second that made devin booker in the
playoffs that's left
okay if you want to be technical that's
not really a pick no but
you gotta go right there let me show you
what
let me show you because right there he
recovered but he tried to
jump there's no help that's why he's
just jumping on
this one first of all this is the
defender that you and chuck was bragging
about
him that ain't no pick he recovered
together he got crushed up stop it
oh no you got crosstalk huh
there's another man there that bro a
void he went under avoiding a man
he went under right if he doesn't but if
he said if there's help there
shaq if if i'm not i'm not saying you're
uh he didn't get crossed up
however he's avoiding someone
and if he doesn't if you're not if
you've got to avoid someone as a point
guard
and if you don't have any kind of help
you're going to get danced on by
steph curry you're going to get danced
on by trey young you're going to paul
george
devin booker no none of those guys i
just named you can guard like that
they will get 50 points and he had 48
tonight he's very good that is
the poster but the big guy
the big guy's got to be in the picture
did you see like
this dude had time to shake shimmy and
line up everything the big guy is
useless
because he's avoiding this i can't get
him all right
we're going for the job you're
recovering we're right there wait right
now i'm trying to jump over the pick
before it comes
because there's no help there's no help
if if they did this if chucky brown was
my floor and
pre-chill cut and those guys i would i
would just be like yo take me out the
game i'm not doing this
i'm not even going to participate in
this i'm not going to participate
if you're going to make me on be on the
island out here and letting god just run
in that house
and you know you're headhunting him you
know and that's to me that's
that's not listen that's an easy one you
can pick any of those plays
well listen lopez had seven points and
one rebound
like if he's not gonna make a difference
and he's just gonna back up every time
and he's not gonna dominate on the
boards he's useless so put somebody out
there
well they can at least be up and make
trey do something the other thing that
you would do if he was up there shaq
when you were there you we huge to do
this
and we used to say shaq's going to do it
so if they go under
if you're guarding akeem and he's
setting that pick you're going to be
bumping akeem
so he's not head hunting me he's not
heading hunting penny hardaway
he's head hunting and he could just
stand there john collins be like okay
wait wait let me go get him
no he's got to be fighting you and
pushing off on him yeah but you know the
one thing you guys are not putting
in consideration maybe trey's in that
category that you can't guard him
on the pick-and-roll no no no no can i
talk can i
can i talk not if you're going to be
wrong let me first of all
wrong you're 100 percent wrong the
pick-and-roll is the most unstoppable
play in basketball right
can you stop chris paul in the figure no
you can you can make it
you can make it deterring can you stop
it he was not deterred there's a
difference between you
can you talk about stopping some guys
but you it's not about you
i could deter him yes could you slow him
down yes you can well
you can't yes you can slow yes you can
but
that way is not going to do anything
listen
no way is going to work oh no no no no
that's not true okay well it's not about
it's not about stopping him it's about
to slowing him down
if you're going to let him come up every
time he's going to get 40. he got 48
points and 11 assists you didn't take
away the pass or you didn't take away
the shots okay but hold on
you step up john collins got a wide open
shot he's down
shooting that's okay you'd rather have
john collins shoot the ball no
disrespect to john collins
just cooking with 48 points